let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [__]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[__] him
[Music]
well good wednesday afternoon
it's three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern you know what time that is
it is time for let's talk to tony
michael's podcast
right here on youtube
twitter
and twitch
we have a lot to talk about today
[Music]
there's gonna be some russians maybe
even some russian salad dressing i just
watched a
short clip of michael flynn talking
about sal dressing these [__] looney
tunes
i don't know that we'll ever get over
this stupid virus in this country they
just can't stop they can't they can't
quit they can not quit
and i have a special announcement to
make we have a special guest episode on
friday
this friday 3 o'clock central four
o'clock eastern you know we do the the
wednesday podcast live i'm live right
here on the air
but we've been doing special guest
episodes where we air them on friday i
record them before but i air them live
so you can see them at three o'clock
central four o'clock eastern on friday
and this friday we have a very very
special guest
you all know him from midas touch
his name is ben mizellis
uh ben and his brothers brett and jordy
came up with midas touch last summer
during the pandemic they were sitting
around in quarantine going how in the
world how in the world can we make sure
that we fight
against the cheeto dust mobster and they
came up with this idea of starting a
super pack he said he didn't even know
what a super pack was that they had to
google the goddamn thing what a super
hack was
so him and his brothers came up with
midas touch and it took off of course we
all know this they've been featured in
variety and
on brian williams 11th hour on msnbc a
whole host of places because of their
video and their media and now they have
podcast ben actually hosts the midas
touch podcast and the legal af podcast
and they and midas touch
has a whole
list of podcasts
so go check those out at minustouch.com
and check out the episode on friday with
ben
i'm gonna play a few clips here and talk
about what we talked about to give you
kind of a preview so you know exactly
what the episode what to expect
but check it out on friday the first
thing i want to do
is make sure i clear things up because
um
i i was trying to get ben to say [__]
them several times so i want to i want
to play a clip to make sure we we
clearly ben has is joining us today on
the podcast i can't believe we have him
here on the podcast i even got him to
say [__] him at least i at least at
least four or five times he said [__]
him [__] him [__] him [__] him [__] him
[__] him
[Music]
he did actually say [__] him several
times i it's just not a video trick
where i repeat him saying but he
actually did he did say [__] him in the
episode several different times and i
think that's maybe a thing we'll do with
guests is try to get them to say [__]
them while they're on the podcast and
then you know clip it up and you know
poke good fun at the phrase [__] them
but we did actually talk about politics
we talked about uh midas touch so check
that out he talks about how that was all
created but we talked about politics in
that what to expect in 2022 that was
part of the the episode that we recorded
and we were talking he was talking
mainly about some of these senate races
and what he thinks about the senate so
let me play a clip of that so what
happens if joe biden wins his midterm
what happens does that give him more
political capital than he even has now
you think what yeah because the dems are
going to increase their the the senate
um seats as well like i i think you
probably get a plus three plus four so
we're at 53 54 in the senate you think
yeah i don't think we have to be as
beholden to
mansion and cinema
if you look at those races generally
a lot of republicans
because
they're sick and they're thinking about
their legacy now too a lot of these
republicans and senate and they're
retiring because they're like i ain't
running i hate running again if i run i
have to say some real crazy [__] and
i've been doing a great job
um you know i've i've have a
legacy a career i'm not going down in
this trumpism crazy stuff and that's why
they're like [__] it [__] them i'm not
doing it
[Music]
so there is more proof that he said [__]
them but what ben is trying to say there
is that democrats have a really good
chance of winning some of these senate
races
just by using the motto in california
alone
the the motto of we don't want trumpism
and you as a special race near and dear
to my heart
is exactly what he said roy blunt here
in missouri is retiring because he
doesn't want to have to say the crazy
[__] that it takes uh to placate to
trumpism and try to win trump's
endorsement
so he bowed out he retired now we have
trump crazies and
with uh billy long
uh eric greitens the disgraced former
governor of missouri and then even this
mccloskey character the guy with the
ar-15 and and st louis
and that that mike parson pardoned him
for his gun crimes
so
i asked him about that race specifically
but i think he's on to something here
that if we can win the three or four
seats that it takes to box out and get
rid of the filibuster but let's see what
else he had to say about some of these
races that chucklehead from st louis
you have him running who parson pardoned
him from his chart his gun charges i
mean this is and that's
what they're going with
in missouri now i don't know if missouri
would or would not elect but i can't
even imagine having any one of those
republicans as a united states senator
anywhere not ju not just missouri but
anywhere i can't imagine it but we do
have lauren boberts and marjorie taylor
greens in the congress so i mean
i don't know do you think races like
that are winnable too just because the
candidates
are so freaking horrible i mean just
just horrible that it could be mickey
mouse running against them and they've
got a chance even in a place like
missouri democrats run
smart elections and i think the
california blueprint is a smart way to
win the election newsom's a fine
candidate he's got his issues but he's a
good candidate and then you have these
psychos who will kill
the light lightly putting it right yeah
you have these psychos who who are
incompetent and couldn't even lead
you know uh you know they couldn't even
lead the book club in a mental ward
so he calls them psychos which they are
they're they're a bunch of psychos i
mean have you seen the the video of
marjie taylor green blowing up a prius
with a gun and she's going to give that
gun away
it's just absolute bonkers whack-a-doo
type [__]
but go thanks to ben i want to thank ben
again right here uh for doing doing the
podcast again it airs on friday we had
some good conversations about the
election we had some good conversations
about minus touch if you want to check
that out uh he tells us
he tells us who the favorite brother is
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
i'm just gonna float it out there that
on the podcast he actually reveals who
the favorite brother is between uh jordy
and brett so go check that out it's near
the end so you might have to watch the
whole thing to figure out who the who
his favorite brother is but go go check
that out
and thank you ben again for for coming
on the podcast so friday three o'clock
central four o'clock eastern uh youtube
twitter twitch it'll broadcast there
so now let's move on to some other news
because there are is a lot of stuff in
the news uh one of the most significant
things to me
is it has to do with the 2016 campaign
and donald trump and taking russian
money it seems to be one of the most
significant stories this week but
there's a lot of distraction happening
and i think i think there's a reason for
a lot of distraction uh because there's
gonna be some more things coming because
we also seen
out of uh the manhattan da's office
there's been whispers that there's more
evidence uncovered in an obscure
basement somewhere
and that there's possibly going to be
more charges filed either against
weisselberg or other co-conspirators
which is not surprising how is anyone
[__] surprised by this that they were
hiding records in a basement somewhere
of course they were i mean this is what
they do is is projection that's why they
keep yammering on and on and on about
hunter biden and his laptop
hunter biden is trending again on
twitter because of his laptop because he
owned a laptop and someone may have
emailed him while he had that laptop and
in the email they may have mentioned his
dad joe biden
how in the what in the [__] is wrong
with you people
number one
biden is not a government official thank
god
i i'm not saying that i'm a fan of
hunter biden
i mean hunter biden has a lot of issues
but he is joe biden's son he loves him
right it's your [__] son so of course
he's gonna love him
but he didn't appoint him to be
secretary of whatever the [__] he wanted
he didn't appoint him to be an advisor
in the white house he's not in control
or over
in power of anything that has anything
to do with the united states government
you [__] idiots understand this right
that the last president the last one has
kids that are just as [__] up as
hunter biden and he put those
[__] in charge of stuff for the
campaign and the actual government like
they couldn't even get security
clearances and they had to override it
that's how [__] bad it was
hunter biden
last week
was selling paintings and they were
losing their minds they wanted to have a
[__] congressional hearing and
have a special counsel and stop the
entire government from operating until
we find out what hunter biden likes to
paint and how much he sells it for when
he sells it or some dumb [__] i don't
know
how the [__] are you supposed to tell
with these people
and then here we are again this week
with laptop stories of how he got emails
on his laptop yes when people own
laptops
sometimes people other people who don't
own the laptop email them and every once
in a while when someone emails them they
talk about other people
especially people that that person who
owns that laptop might know
what in the [__] is wrong with you
[__] idiots
i mean these are the same [__]
same [__] today
mike flynn is talking about
salad dressing having the vaccine in it
what
a lot of people are making the joke that
it might be russian salad dressing but
here's my thought
maybe mike flynn is missing the real
story here maybe breitbart should do a
piece on this
and really get to the bottom of why
liberals are trying to convince trump
supporters on the ivermectin facebook
groups
that
the vaccine is going to be in salad
dressing because my thought is that it's
probably it's probably that liberals
know that they can do a jedi mind trick
on trump supporters
and convince them that the salad
dressing has the bad juice in it
and to not eat salad and then they'll
they'll automatically get overweight and
they'll die of heart attacks it'll be
beautiful it's a beautiful plan just
bear with me bear with me because then
what we can do
is we can win elections that way
we can do that i mean just as opposed to
just going to [__] vote and there's
eight million more votes against
trumpism than there is for trumpism how
about that you dumb [__]
whack-a-doo [__] i mean
seriously we need to maybe consider
having [__] mental institutions in
this country again
this is getting out of [__] hand
these people are are
talking about
the special fauchi juice and salad
dressing
what the num number one that is not
that is that is that's not that's not a
thing
it's not a thing that you just
squirt
squirt the vaccine on your salad and
that's how it work that is not
i repeat that is not how it works that
is
that is [__] it's it's almost it's
almost the same way that iver ivermecton
does not help your covid
it's almost exactly the same that's not
how it works
that's not how any of this works it
really is not
secondly
why salad dressing i mean really if we
wanted to make sure that we were going
to you know
and
get the vaccine to the people who need
it
we would put it in like i don't know
cigarettes or or something like that
not [__] salad dressing
what
i mean
do we think that these these trump
humping
q anon manga evangelical spread necks do
we think that like their favorite food
is salad maybe we'd put them in
cheeseburgers or ribs or i don't know
not [__] salad dressing what are you
people talking about even if that was
our plan even if that was our plan we
wouldn't pick salad dressing are you
[__] dumb
jesus christ i think probably marlboro
reds
is the maybe it's marlboro lights i
don't know i i haven't smoked in a long
time it's been
almost 10 years since i i've quit
smoking so i don't even know
what cigarette brands i'm sure there's
still marlboro reds or camels out there
i don't know
i don't know and i don't know what the
popular cigarette is but we definitely
would not we definitely would not pick
salad dressing if we were trying to
trick you [__] idiots
so the salad dressing false flag
conspiracy is
running rampant throughout the interwebs
in the ivermectin facebook feed feed
store pharmacies on online in the
interwebs
jesus christ
i mean we even have this ashley babbitt
again more distraction she's again
they're talking about ashley babbitt and
they can't say who killed ashley babin
anymore because they know the answer to
that the guy did a [__] national
interview and explained why he was doing
his duty
he explained it like hey was a secure
area i was protecting politicians from a
violent mob
and they were breaking through the door
they broke the window and she was
jumping through the window she even had
a backpack on i didn't know what she had
in the backpack
hello hello
it was a justified use of deadly force
and donald trump convinced ashley
babbitt to go do that
he convinced her at the rally that yeah
it's a good idea to go overthrow the
united states government so i can wipe
the constitution with my orange cheeto
dust ass
go do that for me go
go do that for me
great idea
great idea lethal but great idea
the same way
and she did it
in service to him the same way as if she
wouldn't have been killed that day my
guess is my guess is she may have a
chance of dying from being unvaccinated
you know in service to him because
that's really what they're doing it's
all it's all in service to the cheeto
dust mobster
his grandpa poopy pants
the golden cat republican golden calf
the gqp
the orange deity the mango mussolini
jesus
stop
worshiping of the at the altar of
stupidity
stop it you're killing yourselves and
you're getting governors to kill you
desantis ron desantis in florida
he appoints a surgeon general that's
hates vaccines and hates masks well
whoopity-doo fantastic that's great that
you have a surgeon general who doesn't
give a [__]
about science or community health
fantastic great idea it seems to me like
ron desantis
thinks of the death in his state as
running up the score and boy is he
[__] running it up here lately
craziness [__] craziness
stop
worshiping at the altar of stupidity
and i've said it many many times on here
and i will keep
i will keep saying it
we are at the intersection of
wrestlemania and real life
these people are not tethered to [__]
reality
they don't know what choice is they have
no idea that the choices that they make
have consequences
good choices bad choices in different
choices they all have consequences
and that's your freedom to make those
choices
it's your freedom you get to choose
that's the whole [__] definition of
the word
and when you make choices like not to
get vaccinated sometimes sometimes you
have consequences could be that you end
up on a ventilator and you die and you
leave your family maybe many kids and
your wife or your husband behind
or or it could be it could be that you
lose your goddamn job
because osha is saying now hey hey you
got to keep your workplaces safe they're
companies with a hundred employees or
more you gotta keep them safe those
workplaces like they've always done
that's what osha is for
that's what it's for just like the fda
is for to make sure that vaccines are
appropriate for us citizens
same way same kind of thing you know
it's called oversight to make sure that
we're safe
so the workplaces and oceans tell in the
workplaces you got to keep your
workplaces safe so the workplaces are
going hey if you don't get vaccinated
sorry our workplace isn't safe that's
what osha says they'll find us and we
don't want to get fined so
either get the vaccine or resign
choices you gotta make a choice that's
how it works and there's consequences
for all these choices
all these choices we even had a video
and i posted it on my twitter account
today about a woman who
who was upset that her doctor will not
see her or her kids anymore a
pediatrician specifically because
they're not vaccinated while the doctor
is making a choice you know the doctor's
body the doctor's choice
they don't even know the definition to
the word choice how the [__] are we
supposed to convince these people that
it's okay for hunter biden to own a
laptop
that it's perfectly okay to have him
send it in for repair that ashley
babbitt got killed with
a lawful use of deadly force because
she's a terrorist
and to convince mike flynn that there's
no fouchy juice in your salad dressing
holy
[__]
there's actual [__] going on like real
[__] [__]
i mean even more craziness is donald
trump is now suing mary trump and the
new york times for her book
well that's kind of late isn't it i mean
you should have sued her months ago oh
that's right i know why distraction
and it's true
it's the
truth it's the truth if it was lies he
wouldn't give a [__]
it's the truth
he's gonna threaten her with a hundred
million dollar lawsuit same way with the
new york times that's apparently the
word
and of course
he's not gonna win
he doesn't win anything just like mary
trump said he's a [__] loser
he's been a loser his whole [__] life
he's a [__] loser he lost in the late
80s early 90s and and russia [__]
held him up
he he [__] couldn't be a real
business person so he had to go on tv
and pretend to be one
he lost the the
the popular vote in the first election
in 2016
how he even lost the goddamn crowd
competition and his inauguration
and then he lost by the largest [__]
margin ever the most votes ever piled on
top of him
in 2020 he's a [__] loser
and trump isn't [__] lost in
california in the recall and my guess is
my guess is trumpism is going to be
another [__] loser in virginia
that's my guess
[__] loser
you're a [__] loser
grandpa poopypants
but we have real [__] news we have
real [__] that's going on not salad
dressing and and laptops and and
and who emailed who well
wait
even who emailed who that's kind of a
funny thing
they are still bitching
about hillary clinton's emails they
can't stop [__] contemplating about
hunter bite the emails that are on
hunter biden's laptop
they're so focused on emails my guess is
i would bet that it's projection
it is everything is projection with
these [__] fools
everything
so what you gotta do is you really gotta
look at i don't know maybe maybe some
stories that are in the news
that have a lot to do with i don't know
let's just pick something out emails
let's do that let's pick out some
stories with possible evidence with
emails
the first story is of course the story
we all know the big lie and sydney
powell
and and and lynn wood looney tunes lynn
wood and then mike flynn
rudy grandpa farty mcshardy giuliani
these [__] running around the country
trying to sell the big lie to anyone who
will [__] listen
about dominion and smartmatic and these
voting machines mike lindell the the my
pillow nazi mustache mussolini is the
same he's in the same [__] group of
people
even though he's not a lawyer he he
makes pillows i don't even understand
how that happened how the [__] did we
get the pillow guy
into the history of our country i mean
literally he's right bam right there he
was standing at the [__] white house
ready to go in talk to the cheeto dust
mobster about how the pillow guy had
this great idea on how he was going to
overturn the election and we're still
listening to him apparently uh august
wasn't actually the uh
the the thing where he was where trump
was gonna ascend down from maga heaven
and
you know
covered in cheeto dust and i don't know
ascend to the presidency or and they
would all worship at the altar of
his shitty diapers i don't know i don't
know
but what i do know is mike lindell is a
crazy [__]
and dominion is gonna sue him sidney
powell and all these dumb bucks
and they don't give a [__] and they got
evidence i would guess
my guess is because i would guess that
they didn't use the pony express to
communicate i would almost bet
almost bet
in those civil trials and the
depositions we're gonna hear the word i
don't know
emails that's probably the word we're
gonna hear as far as evidence because
apparently there is evidence to show
that these [__] idiots knew that
there was no fraud
they knew they made it all up
they made it all up
all of it
ah
who would have thought that you could
actually make [__] like that up
the thing the question that i have and i
think everyone around the country is is
debating this
is
isn't this a crime
i mean isn't i mean you know you can
stand in front of a microphone and you
know say whatever you want but they were
fire filing federal lawsuits
like they were trying to coerce the
court
to be
complicit in this fraud
isn't that i mean
rudy giuliani went to state legislators
under oath
he went and testified in state after
state after state under oath
isn't that
is it that purge there's a word it's
purger
prayer jury purge perjury i i don't know
i don't know
but aren't some of these things crimes i
mean this is fraud
if they really didn't know
that it was all lies and they were
filing lawsuits in federal court and
state courts
they were petitioning state legislators
they were under oath testifying in front
of state legislators
i think that
might be i don't know
criminal
possibly i don't know i'm not a lawyer
so i wouldn't know
i definitely probably wouldn't ask
lynnwood sydney power rudy giuliani
their legal opinion because i what i
hear they don't even have legal license
anymore
so they're getting desperate
is my is my uh
my take on it
when they keep talking about emails
emails
emails hunter bites emails hillary
clinton's emails emails emails emails i
would imagine
that we need to look into their email
it's always projections with these
[__]
boneheads because there's also another
big story
and i believe uh
this one of two big stories when it
comes to
these trump-humping maga
fools
is this story about jesse benton
now just to refresh your memory and this
is a long ways back
long ways back i mean you know it's not
that long in years but political time
this is like eons ago
in 2012 during the republican primary in
iowa
there was a guy running named ron paul
now it sounds familiar
like a big perm rand paul but it's ron
paul
it's rand paul's father
so it's it's daddy [__]
okay
so ron paul was running for president
and he was running in the republican
primary in iowa
and jesse benton i i believe he was a
republican a state republican party
official at the time
and it was
he was convicted of bribing officials to
support ron paul
yeah you know that doesn't go over very
well in federal court
well this jesse benton also worked on
the rand paul campaign and there's
another guy work for in kentucky his
name is mitch mcconnell hmm
these dots always connect each other
have you noticed that
the craziest part is
that there's also another dot that
connects jesse benton to republicans and
that is apparently the trump campaign in
2016.
so in 2016 jesse benton apparently
according to the court
according to prosecutors
they claim
that he petitioned and got a hundred
thousand dollars from russians
to get into the trump campaign now there
was a trade because you never have the
cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopy pants
the orange dd the mango mussolini jesus
you never never ever ever have him in a
story where he's receiving money where
he's not getting something in return or
someone's not getting something to turn
it's always a quid pro quo there's
always a transaction you give me
something i'll give you something or i
give you something you give me something
well apparently that something was a
a promised meeting
at a fundraiser
in philadelphia
with russians and trump hmm
now
it's very
we're not going to know the facts of
this until it really reaches a certain
point
in discovery but it seems as if this
hundred thousand dollar number is not
the only number involved it seems like
some of this money was lost right it
just poof disappeared and probably went
in someone's pocket and you you out
there as the audience can only imagine
whose [__] pocket it ended up in my
guess is the hundred dollar bills have
cheeto dust on them
now
jesse
benton is not the only one charging this
there's also another guy his name is
doug weed
um so there's two gentlemen charged in
this
but i find it really really really
convenient
that liberals
and rachel maddow and msnbc and cnn
and and the democrats in congress had
trump derangement syndrome when it came
to russia in 2016
and the connection the collusion
remember no abstraction no collusion
it really seems convenient that now
we're finding out in federal criminal
court that there was someone not only
with the trump campaign taking a hundred
thousand dollars to put in the trump
campaign from russians
and the trade was a meeting
now the other thing that's funny
that ties trump to this jesse benton
case is trump pardoned jesse benton
of his crime of bribery in iowa
back in 2012 right before he left office
now
having known that trump would never ever
ever give a meeting away to russians at
a fundraiser in philadelphia unless they
gave someone a hundred thousand dollars
allegedly
i would bet
that the pardon that was given to jesse
benton
was in return
for something
that's how it works with the cheeto dust
mobster
when he gets his cheeto dust
fingerprints on something it's all over
the place
and i would bet
that the pardon was a quid pro quo
and i would imagine that the reason why
trump pardoned jesse benton is because
he knew
what was going to happen and of course
he's a [__] buffoon and he thought
well i'll pardon him from the past crime
where he bribed
officials and took with the illegal
money and that'll exonerate him from any
future crimes that he would have been
committed from that he committed
it's a trade
that's what i think
looks like it it looks like a trade to
me
looks like a trade to me jesse benton
trades a hundred thousand dollars for a
promise of a meeting with trump
it's the court's saying so documents say
it's what the the indictment says are
six [__] counts on each one of these
[__] scumbags
benton and weed
six federal counts
so it looks like that
we'll see in court they pled not guilty
which is par for the course but we'll
see if there's any superseding
indictments if it rakes anyone else in
you're gonna hear that word a lot
superseding indictment you're gonna hear
that phrase a lot
a lot the next 12 months
but it would seem to me if there is a
trade for a hundred thousand dollars for
a meeting why wouldn't there be a trade
for a pardon for benton for his charge
in iowa
in 2012 because he's a felon and then
pardon will wipe a felony off your
record that's the trade
i'll trade you to clean your record if
you trade me
i don't know maybe if the feds ever come
around you just keep your mouth shut
i don't know i'm just i'm just tossing
out ideas here
of why jesse benton was so lucky to get
a pardon
why
because we know
we know he also pardoned someone from
the inaugural committee
i was being charged with the inaugural
committee and what is also funny about
the jesse benton the inaugural committee
charges and someone else who's been
charged in a federal court
under federal indictment
when it comes to foreign money
tom barrack who's tied to donald trump
he was taking saudi and uae money
illegally
hmm
then we have then we have the rudy
giuliani case when it comes to ukraine
a ukrainian his ukrainian operative is
his inside man or whatever the [__]
i don't even know if rudy even knows
what the [__] going on anymore if
you've seen this last speech he gave he
he could barely manage to make his
tongue make words
you have the rudy giuliani case that is
heating up
you have someone very close to him in
the case
that is pled guilty yeah that seems like
a deal
i would say there's other superseding
indictments coming in that case
and that has to do with foreign bribery
it just doesn't stop with these [__]
idiots
and then we find out this week another
big story
that they're trying to bury with hunter
biden and ashley babbitt and sal
addressing
vaccines
another story that they're trying to
bury is the story in the manhattan da's
office
because
it's been told they found
pallets of evidence in a basement i
don't know who knows
who knows it's
these people
i mean how can you tell they're putting
they're hiding documents and basements
it's not surprising
really isn't that we hear that
what we do know is it seems like there's
possibly going to be more indictments of
ghost conspirators in that case
or another superseding indictment of
alan weisselberg and the trump
organization
again with the superseding indictment
but it's kind of funny all these cases
that i'm talking about all of them every
[__] last one of them
all of them
there's one thing that connects them all
one
one [__] thing i mean it's a
big thing it's a nasty thing
it can't keep his [__] mouth shut
thing
he can't just let it go go [__]
retire maybe you'll won't face criminal
indictment type thing
one name one buffoon one [__] box
only one trump
he connects all these cases all of them
well [__] he even connects the joel
greenberg case down in florida where
he's
flipping on matt getz
because the word is is that
one of the reasons it got exposed is
because joel greenberg knew he was going
to face these federal charges for sex
trafficking so he petitioned
roger stone to get him to tell jared
kushner and rudy giuliani those names
pop up again somewhere
to get to get grandpa poopy pants to
give him a pardon
i my guess is my guess is is that trump
wasn't confident that joe greenberg
would make the trade
you know like jesse benton did
seems kind of convenient doesn't it it
all seems real convenient
but there's always always only one thing
one thing in common with these [__]
cases i mean [__] even the sydney cow
dome the the sydney pal linwood mike
lindell
dominion smartmatic case
has trump in common it's a civil case
but it's the same [__]
it's the same [__]
the same [__] and who knows who knows
what trump traded to those people to get
to go out there and intentionally lie
and commit fraud
and sell the big lie who the [__] knows
we may find out we may not there's so
much [__] garbage in this dumpster
i mean it it's overwhelming and that's
the point
is more chaos more chaos
more chaos
the more chaos the better you know we'll
be able to distract you more
that's why they keep stoking this fire
of this anti-vaxx movement they're
continuing this [__]
because
if coronavirus wasn't such an issue
in this country if we could actually get
this pandemic under control which we can
i believe we can
we can
if we could get a certain percentage of
the population
to knock it off and actually listen to
what the [__] the science and the
medical professionals are saying
instead of uncle ned
on the ivermecton facebook pharmacy
group
if we could get this pandemic under
control
trumpism might fade away what are they
going to be what the hell are they going
to [__] about then
i really think
hunter biden's laptop is enough to get
30 percent of the country riled up
to commit another insurrection
nope
sure isn't
that's just this week's distraction his
paintings his paintings that he sold
were last week's distraction
maybe maybe the the email hunter lot
hunter biden's laptop thing didn't play
very well so now they're going with
salad dressing for the rest of the week
you know that the latter half of the
week is salad dressing
but that's how they're continuing this
this it's this garbage because if they
can sell them the big lie
about coronavirus these people are i
mean
it's very clear what's happening
it's not ambiguous it's
and they they they believe that it's
fake news that everyone is conspiring
against them including the doctors the
hospitals the nurses everybody it's all
it's all for show it's actually i don't
know
you can't hardly tell what they believe
anymore especially from the breitbart
article
i mean there's they're surmising out
there and conservative media
that this was all big plan
by liberals to pull them jedi mind trick
on trump supporters so that they
wouldn't get vaccinated
that somehow by us saying go get
vaccinated please go get vaccinated it's
what we want you to do to stay healthy
and not die they're like ah no you said
it i'm not gonna do it
which i mean if that's really the truth
if the truth is is that's how they act
if if libtards
say something and they do the opposite
just because libtards say something
that's like a thing that a 12 year old
does you realize that right
like that's not a thing adults normally
do that's a thing that children do
like when you got kids
a lot of people out there have had kids
and you know the kid gets to be almost a
teenager they're gonna do everything
that you say not to do
you gotta be careful what you tell a kid
sometime not to do because they just
might do it
because they're children
they haven't developed their [__]
critical thinking part of their brain
yet fully well
apparently we have adults in this
country who have not developed that part
of their [__] brain
maybe the ivermectin has faded it away i
don't know
taking horse dewormer cannot cannot be
good
for the old thinky space
but here we are
here we are amongst big lies so if you
can sell those type of lies
and you can sell the election fraud lie
why can't you sell other lies
they're all on sale they're having a big
blowout
and it's all quid pro quo
because we heard this garbage for four
years that russia you're crazy you have
trump derangement syndrome everything is
russia to you people it's all conspiracy
theory about russia
russia russia russia russia
i mean remember he kept repeating the
same [__] stupid [__] no obstruction
no collusion no obstruction no collusion
no obstruction no collusion no
obstruction no collusion no obstruction
no collusion well there was collusion
that's what the court is alleging there
was [__] collusion it was in the form
of a hundred thousand dollars
a hundred thousand not only collusion
they were [__] paying each other
to collude
they were selling their collusion it was
on sale
of course everything's on sale with that
[__]
i mean jesus christ did you see the
moony video that he did with the moonies
this cult this gun cult they wear
[__] bullet crowns and [__] have gold
guns they're weird it's [__] weird
it's [__] weird
it's weird in some of this ivermectin
[__] this horse dewormer feed store
antiseptic [__]
it's weirder than that i know it's hard
to believe that it gets that weird but
it's [__] weird
he did a video for them and it looked
like a hostage video but you know he got
paid to say that [__] cuz he didn't he
didn't he didn't know that [__] he
didn't know what he was saying he was
just reading
sort of
but he'll do anything for money of
course he would have colluded for money
what do you think the whole purpose was
when he came down the escalator and
started talking about how mexican a
rapist
that's that's the whole point the whole
point was to collude for money he was
selling his he was selling his collusion
that's the whole [__] point and now
now we're gonna find out
we're gonna find out how much whether it
was a hundred thousand dollars or more
money or whatever
i'm sure i'm sure mr jesse benton
and doug weed which doug weeds probably
the real target here because doug weed
doesn't sound like he has a pardon that
was given for his silence i'm just i
mean i'm not saying that's exactly what
happened but it looks like it
it looks like jesse benton was given a
pardon to wipe away his felony you know
keep your mouth shut about that hundred
thousand dollars that we took from
russia and i stuffed a bunch of it in my
pocket keep that quiet
seems kind of convenient
and all the while
all the while
democrats in congress still trust these
republicans
still trusting them we've before i came
on air reading a story about tim scott
it was all set up it was all set up
this this [__] policing bill and
negotiating policing bill
and that was all
set up to [__] fail it was a whole
point
just to make democrats feel like they
were actually doing something in the
[__] media
they need to stop this [__] you need to
go with my [__] phrase and say [__]
them we're gonna get rid of the
filibuster we're gonna do what the [__]
we want they would do what the [__] they
wanted they did what the [__] they
wanted i mean jesus that's why we're so
close to roe v wade being overturned
because they didn't [__] give a [__]
they don't care they don't give a [__]
you need to stop giving a [__] stop
giving a [__] and do the right thing
that's what you need to do
you want to know how when elections
democrats do you want to know how
do you want to know
stop listening to the [__] crazies
and just do what the majority of the
country wants you to do there's a fox
news poll that shows almost 70 percent
of [__] people in this country in a
fox news poll
that want schools
school districts to mandate masks for
children because they want their
children healthy and safe
we're going to have another [__]
stupid fight here over this [__]
vaccine when pfizer eventually approves
5 to 11 year olds it's going to be
another [__] it's gonna be chaos
because you won't just say ah we're not
we're gonna ignore you
we're not gonna give you a microphone
you don't get to sit at the table
anymore you do not get to negotiate
we're not going to negotiate with you
you have no [__] clue what you're
doing
you have no clue what the what the
[__] country wants you're only
listening to the [__] facebook fans
we're done
let's just do what the country wants
which is passing
voting rights reform get it [__]
passed get our voting rights protected
get them back
ratify the era
make make women's bodies the autonomy of
their bodies constitutional
do it
pass infrastructure
get internet to everyone who doesn't
have it
fix the [__] roads fix the [__]
bridges
fix the [__] health care system all
that stuff is infrastructure
do it
that is the thing that you need to do
so just say [__] them [__] them
and do what the country wants do what
you're supposed to do do your [__]
job
pass a [__] policing bill stop toying
around with [__] tim scott
stop it
it's all a [__] trick it's all
[__]
it's all of it
all of it just like the hunter biden
emails the ashley babbitt the salad
dressing
sydney powell and the big lie it's all
[__]
all of it
it's all [__] [__]
we elected you go do what you're gonna
do
and we talk about this a little bit on
friday's podcast uh you've seen some
clips we go over some of the the
elections that are gonna happen
what what 2022 actually means in this
country because i think that
2022 is
is gonna be
the match to what it's gonna be a huge
battle it's 2016 and 2020 are not going
to hold a candle
to the chaos
and the absolute delusion and the lies
and the [__]
that we're gonna see we think we think
[__] hunter binds emails ashley
babbitt's
uh being a martyr and and salad dressing
and ivermectin and antiseptic
we haven't even began
to see
the [__] craziness that is about to
ensue
on this country with these with these
nut jobs these wackadoos these q anon
maga trump bumpers this 12 13 of the
[__] country they call themselves the
silent majority but they're the loudest
[__] minority we've ever [__] had
ever and the reason why is because the
[__] jelly is normally spread out
crust the crust on the toast
and it's spread really thin
it's not anymore all our crazies are in
one [__] spot on the peanut butter
and jelly sandwich
and it tastes like [__]
you want the jelly you know you want the
jelly really spread out on your peanut
butter and jelly sandwich
the peanut butter too you know you don't
want to put it all like right in the
middle that doesn't make any [__]
sense like you want to spread it out a
bit
you know get it maybe even over the
crust you know so you can you know what
you do you get it over the crust and you
lick the edge of the sandwich because
it's got that nice
jelly and peanut butter kind of just
oozing out of the crust you know what
i'm talking about
you don't make a peanut butter sandwich
with all the ingredients right in the
middle the crazies are all lumped into
the middle of the sandwich we need to
spread them out
they used to be like flat earthers and
jfk conspiracy theorists
people who believe in aliens and bigfoot
like they were all over the map right
they were all over the map
it was nice and spread thin you know
you're like oh that's kind of funny they
believe in bigfoot
that's kind of that's kind of weird
right nope nope nope
if they [__] they're on facebook now
and they all have groups and they're all
members of all these groups
and they believe all this [__] [__]
all of it
and they're all in one spot and the spot
is maga the q anon maga trump bumping
spread next evangelicals white people
so democrats don't believe the [__]
don't believe it just say [__] them
we we are going to vote vote vote vote
vote
have your head on your shoulders
show that you want policy
show us that you want
to do the things that we want you to do
and we will vote for you
we will vote for even if it's just
because the other person
is a [__] trumper and they're off
their goddamn rocker like ldl larry
elder was in california
and he stomped knew some stomp the [__]
out of him essentially because the race
was essentially against gavin newsom and
larry elder
and it was a
rebuke on trumpism
and i believe the next race we're going
to have is virginia so virginians out
there who can vote
go
vote show your support
vote vote vote vote vote against
trumpism
vote against it
i believe that a lot of people in this
country are going to get out on election
day and they're going to crawl over hot
coals and beds of nails
to vote against trumpism
now we need to have good candidates
we need to have good candidates
we need to have candidates that are
actually going to do some [__] and have
some balls and say [__] them it's enough
for this [__] we're not going to
negotiate with tim scott when we know
it's all [__] in the first place
it's all ruse for mitch mcconnell to
keep police reform off the goddamn floor
of the senate [__] that [__] [__] that
[__] get a bill put it on the senate
floor get rid of that [__] filibuster
i don't even want you to reform it
anymore you had your chance to reform it
you've had [__] you've had [__]
almost eight months to reform it
and get it to be a standing filibuster
enough of that [__] get rid of that
[__] toss it out that's that's
not part of what we originally
wanted anyways get rid of that
[__]
[__] them
parliamentarian says you can't put
something in a bill [__] them fire them
hire a new parliamentarian that's what
republicans would do
we need to get off our asses we need to
grow some [__] balls and we need to
stop
stop being so goddamn akin to oh well
norms norms they are breaking all the
norms and destroying
our democratic republic that is their
goal
that is their goal
that's their goal so maybe we should
consider breaking some of those norms to
save it
maybe just maybe
my guess is is that we should pick
candidates that are gonna do that
because if we do have if we do have
three to four extra seats
that gives us 53 or 54. you only need
to kill that [__] filibuster
to kill it dead
for good
not reform the bastard [__] it you had
your chance you had your chance mansion
had your chance to reform it we get 51
senators kill that [__] do you
know what else is the main key here
to the senate
if we win the senate if joe biden
keeps the house and increases his margin
in the house
and he wins the senate with a larger
margin than he has right now which is
the thai vote
because he won the presidency and kamala
harris is the presiding officer of the
senate and she gets the vote and the
tiebreaker
so if he wins those two by larger
margins
that is going to give him more political
capital to do anything that he wants to
do and the reason why is because
presidents don't win their midterms
look back just recent history trump lost
his obama lost his midterm
clinton lost it
you lose your midterm
unless there's a crazy event like 911
it switches
because that's what the country does
is our political
our political memory is very short
but as long as trump keeps yapping and
talking and carrying on with the crazy
and these [__] evangelical maga trump
pumping queueing on
spread necks keep showing up at school
board meetings and yelling and screaming
nonsense into a microphone and they keep
saying stupid [__] about salad dressing
and airing it on the internet yeah yeah
we're gonna pay attention our memory is
gonna be really short because let me
tell you
school board meetings
salad dressing hunter biden's emails
how ash
how ashley babbitt died
married trump lawsuits the big lie
election fraud uh
apparently
kelly loffler's somebody getting blown
up in a in a car
bamboo ballots
on and on and on it goes the craziness
yeah you keep up with the crazy you keep
up with it
we're probably gonna [__] remember
how crazy you are
so get out there and [__] vote
go [__] vote hashtag go [__] vote
i think that's gonna be my new uh
my new
uh
phrase we got [__] them but i think go
[__] vote go [__] vote that's how
we're gonna fix this [__] go [__]
vote go register to vote
figure out where you vote how you vote
when you can vote and go [__] vote
go [__] vote
go [__] vote repeat it over and over
and over again go
[__]
vote that's how we keep this thing
called democracy that's how we keep our
republic that's how we give women and
texas their [__] autonomy of their
bodies back give them back their [__]
liberty that texas is trying to take
from them that they're going to try to
take in mississippi and every [__]
red state there is that's how we do it
vote vote vote vote vote go [__] vote
one other thing
one other thing before i forget [__]
them
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them